so let's talk about call of duty none of
you seem to be
very happy with your chosen game at the
moment
we've got modern warfare fans who are
feeling left behind
we have cold war fans who are being
driven into war zone unnecessarily and
we have warzone fans dealing with 30
shall we say not so great balanced
weapons being dumped into their game i'm
joined here by richie bracamonte our
local call of duty expert
and we're gonna kind of go over some of
the things that you guys are all unhappy
about
and maybe how we got here and some of
the things we can
do to fix it as always make sure you
guys give us the old thumbs up on
youtube and subscribe to the channel if
you guys want to talk about more call of
duty
all right let's get into it richie why
don't you talk a little bit about
kind of like the development cycle and
how you think we actually got here
sure so the development cycle for cold
war was shifted sort of at the last
minute
it was reported that sledgehammer games
and raven were supposed to work on the
next game
but i think to ride the coattails and
the successful wave of the modern
warfare reboot
cold war wanted to jump in and sort of
do the same thing so treyarch got
involved at the last minute
uh and that that that brings us to where
we are now this merger of
cold war and war zone specifically is
steamrolling the modern warfare universe
with all their guns and
they're kind of stitching this
connection together between both
universes
sort of being in the same timeline on
paper it was very bold and when i first
heard about it i was like no way they're
going to pull this off it's a rumor
but it's happening here we are and it's
kind of a mess uh
so many guns were introduced haphazardly
and said the system
an entirely different system like
literally on
there are two different systems that are
being fused together to try to
play nice between both games and it's
rushed it was rushed it was pretty rough
and it's being
slowly ironed out uh as far as guns go
but
it was a rough launch and a lot of
people weren't happy some were because
of the overpoweredness of some specific
guns
the design philosophy between the two
games is so different that it
it it's worse than just 30 guns being
added so like cold war weapons if you
play
black ops cold war um those guns don't
have the nuances of modern warfare so
modern warfare has an attachment system
with like very very specific pros and
cons
and you could put an attachment on a gun
that'll make some areas of the gun
better and some worse
whereas cold war tended to not have that
it was more of a traditional call of
duty game so adding these weapons into
warzone which is what they both share
that that have very few weaknesses
and only get better as you add
attachments versus
the modern warfare guns it made many of
them like instantly overpowered
now that being said it kind of seems
like that they took mostly just the
models from cold war
and did the best they could to put some
semblance of similarities between them
for example the monolithic suppressor
is on cold war guns it's just called
something else but all this just led to
like a lot of
a lot of confusion and the perception
that the game had just been
war zone at least had been just
completely broken so if warzone is the
the shared experience between cold war
and modern warfare
richie what's this like for just for
modern warfare players who've been
who've been playing this game for over a
year now the core experience is still
there
it's it's still fun to play um it's
probably
as good as it's going to get at this
point it was it was a
modern warfare we both agree did a lot
of things right um
but right now it's kind of getting
forgotten like aside from the
progression system which is
shared between three titles um
modern warfare as a standalone you know
game isn't
is lacking the support already which is
common because you know the new game is
out in fact
and one new game is out and one game is
still like
uh warzone is still heavily being used
right now by
like everyone it's it's a fan favorite
but it
that whole engine that whole system was
based on modern warfare and i know
modern warfare players are still out
there for sure
but they're getting the shaft with
everything with any sort of update
and it sucks this time around
specifically
it stings because that was such a good
game and it
had a big player base that i think is
still very much there
but they're expecting you to go to go to
war zone
your battle pass in this in modern
warfare is like a slap in the face
because
it's all for like you can unlock things
but they're for
war zone which they just assume you play
or cold war which you might not even own
you can buy the the season pass from
within modern warfare not knowing that
it only encompasses cold war
and it's even worse than that because
you can do things like you think you've
unlocked the mach 10
which is the overpowered gun in war zone
you can see the model of the mac 10
from modern warfare um but
when you go into your smg category it's
not there and
that's because it's not a gun that you
can use in the core modes
but to make things even more kind of
galling
um warzone runs on the modern warfare
engine
so the mac 10 is in the modern warfare
engine
it is in the game they just simply won't
allow you to use it
within modern warfare so it's so weird
you've basically paid for something in
one game
and you're getting progression in one
game that is only tied to a completely
separate game that you might not own
and it kind of gives you this like this
uh i don't know
consolation prize where you can you can
use it in warzone
but yeah it feels kind of scummy like
it's weird how modern warfare has been
completely erased
yeah definitely it's being forgotten
like today i was
playing a little modern warfare
multiplayer and i unlocked a blueprint
for
the m16 uh and i was like oh there it is
they lay it out on the table but it's
like this gun is not available
in modern warfare just as a standalone
game so i was like what
wait what the hell like i forgot that
it's just
it's messy and scummy like don't show me
that uh
i don't assuming assume i don't have
cold war you know don't assume everyone
does
yeah in a weird way it'd be better if
they just hit it and like it didn't
actually show up until you opened cold
war
okay so that's why modern warfare
players probably aren't too happy right
now they feel like they've been left
behind
uh forgotten a bit so why are cold war
players also not happy right now
because they have the brand new game
they have their own game it's brand new
you're right
but if they're trying to get the full
experience then the integration with
warzone
we talked about this whole system and
how it's completely different
um it's it's like it may not be going
backwards for some people but it's a
different style of gameplay
you need longer range guns and if you're
comfortable with the cold war guns
a lot of them don't carry over well that
well into
war zone it'll seem like a different
experience entirely and even down to the
little things like kicking open a door
is a thing in warzone super sprinting
mounting guns
if you're playing warzone it's fine but
if you're coming from cold war and you
wanted to check out
warzone it's a little jarring for sure
and
the hopefully that'll be solved with the
upcoming rumored
new cold war-based war zone map
which is all the dirty bomb maps
combined so they're saying so the rumor
is
but that won't come for a while
fortunately war zone is free so you know
you don't have to take it or leave it
but you know if you want the full
experience right now it's not a good
time to
dip your toes into both if you're new
warzone is modern warfare was broken
away from modern warfare it runs on
modern warfare's engine
so a lot of what we're seeing you know
people out there saying is they're
really not happy to be forced into this
other game
which is war zone to complete the
challenges
from cold war there's also just like
weird little things like
um the button presses for certain menus
like challenges are different in each
game and it's just a weird jarring
transition for people who just wanted to
play cold war and didn't want to play
modern warfare i mean these are two very
different audiences
it's hard to like stress that enough
it's like old school call of duty versus
milsim
inspired folks who who didn't want
traditional call of duty all right so
back to warzone richie there's some
other things that you've noticed going
on in the game that's kind of ruining
the experience for everybody why don't
you dig into that for sure we're talking
about hackers it's a uh
very hot topic right now a new one uh
in some ways because there have always
been hackers in
uh war zones since launch things like
aimbotting and
uh shooting through walls and uh
anything like that advanced controller
mods people are adding their own
hardware to just hack
but there are new sort of problems
popping up
based on what sort of router you use and
you're able to get into special lobbies
where
players they call them bot lobbies
because the players are so low level
that they just feel like bots
and it's really controversial and uh in
in terms of
competitive call of duty where that's
like obviously not allowed
uh it's a big problem in the streaming
community and the the youtuber community
you know people are finagling their way
into
these lobbies and making themselves look
good and it's just not
cool it's not allowed and it's it's the
latest thing right now
so uh we're not happy to see it and it's
hard to
sort of apparently it's hard to fix this
sort of problem because activision is
uh not working on it i would say
uh currently i think they're starting to
become aware of this
sort of specific issue but it's hard to
it's hard to fix
all this stuff at once there's always
something going on in terms of
hacking or problems like technical
issues with warzone and this is just
sort of the thing of the week
all right so sort of high level um just
real quick
so nobody's happy modern warfare people
have been
erased to a certain extent cold war
players are being forced into war zone
and war zone players are seeing
issues with uh weapons and also cheating
richie what do you think activision can
kind of focus on
next to bring all these like studios and
and games together
you know to the extent that's realistic
in the near future
um i did always fantasize about just
tearing them apart and keeping these
universes separate but i don't think
it's going to happen
so i suggest and and i'm hopeful that
they can just
fix these issues um on a on a bigger
scale
because it's it's these little granular
things that really mess up the
experience
uh they become more than granular uh
when they're not
uh accounted for and when they're not
fixed it just becomes a glaring issue so
fix what you have now because i love
warzone at its core
and the idea of an integration was cool
so let's just
keep it going but fix it that's all i
can hope for
the idea of doubling down on warzone is
a is a good one they need to get back
into what
you know apex does or or fortnite really
get into those map events and get
people's excitement back
up in the future uh like obviously it
wasn't possible this time but they do
need to get all their games on the same
engine
so you don't run on run into these like
awkward situations switching back and
forth between mechanics it really
seems like uh modern warfare is the
future it's it's more of a platform
than a game in my opinion and i think
they could really double down on
just building on top of that but yeah
like i
i do want to stress that the idea was
good
and the idea that you can play any call
of duty game and and cross-progress
between other call of duty games is
awesome as we mentioned maybe they ought
to hide that
when you're in one game and just give
you everything at once when you get to
the other game
so you don't feel like you're awkwardly
progressing in a game you don't own
just bring it all together same engine
cross progression cross play
and um maybe not dump 30 weapons in a
war zone
in one go right it was ambitious but
maybe a little too ambitious and it had
a rocky launch for sure
all right well we want to hear what you
guys think are you also
equally unhappy with your uh your call
of duty game of choice right now
or is everything going great and and you
know you're sitting pretty
richie and i also make a ton of other
call of duty content don't forget to
check out our broken guns
part 1 and 2 where we go through all of
call of duty history and call out your
favorite
most broken weapons and again if you
guys get that chance
give us the old thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel alright thank you so much
for watching everybody
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you